في شمال السوري تفرقت المصالح وتضاربت
الاجندات بين تركيا وروسيا والولايات
المتحده فامام المعارضه الروسيه
والامريكيه لعمليه باليه تركيه عالمه
الجزيره من مصدر رسمي تركي ان انقره وضعت
شروطا وحددت مهله للامريكيين والروس من
اجل ان تتراجع عن الحمله البريه الموعوده
حدد تركيا شروطها في اخراج ما تعرف بقوه
سوريا الديمقراطيه من منبج وتل رفعت وعين
العرب كوباني شمال سوريا وانهاء سيطرت هذه
القوه على المنشات النفطيه وذلك قبل النظر
في المقترحات الامريكيه لانقره
ومقترحاته واشنطن يتعلق باعاده هيكله ما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه بمنح دور
اكبر للمكون العربي في اداره منبج وتل
رفعت وعين العرب كوباني على الجانب الاخر
قدم روسيا عرضها ووضعت شروطها فقد عرضت
رفع الغطاء عن منطقه الشهباء في ريف حلب
وعين العرب لتسهيل دخول القوات التركيه
اليه
اما شروطها فقال المصدر التركي انها تتعلق
بتنازلات في الملف الاوكراني ماذا ان لم
تتحقق الشروط وتجاوز الزمن المهله التركيه
المصدر الرسمي التركي ابلغ الجزيره ان
البديل سيكون تنفيذ العمليه العسكريه
البريه التي تعد لها انقره تاكيدا لذلك
قال الرئيس التركي ان بلاده ستنهي ما وصفه
بالارهاب في شمال سوريا وانها قادره على
تحقيق انتصارات لا يتوقعها احد تركي تريلا
مجاديده بخصوص كفاح هذه الارهاب تعمل
تركيا على انهائه اينما كان اذا كان في
سوريا فنحن لن ندفعه للذهاب الى داخلها بل
سننهيه في شمالها يخرج البعض الالي يقول
لنا لا يمكنكم القيام بهذا وذاك في كوباني
لم يعد هناك شيء اسمه كوباني كوباني انتهت
ومن قال انه لا يمكننا القيام باي شيء
هناك
يبدو بذلك عامل الزمن محدودا امام المساعد
دبلوماسيه الروسيه والامريكيه ثمت على
الارض ما يؤكد مديه تركيا قدما في
الاستعداد للعمل العسكري البري مع استمرار
عمليات القصف بالمدفعيه والطائرات المسيره
فقد قصف الجيش التركي تجمعات ومراكز لما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في قرن
بمحيطه الابيض في الرقه وعين العرب في ريف
حلب على الحدود مع تركيا اضافه الى ريف
الحسكه